this lesson and the following one's are
designed to give you the tools to build
designs that scale across multiple
devices now one of the first challenges
with developing for the mobile web is
the display screen the typically small
display screen compared to a desktop or
a laptop device it really forces you to
focus on what's critical for you users
in fact this is what's led to the recent
adoption of the mantra mobile first now
mobile first isn't about designing for
the mobile web before you even think
about the desktop experience it's really
a design philosophy of stripping down to
your core user experience and then
layering additional gravy on top if you
have the appropriate space for example
you might put your company info links
inside a menu rather than cluttering up
your home screen with them